all right welcome back everyone to my
Round 4 recap from The Rake of open in
this game I was playing video Master
Gregory markson from America
and uh yeah I traveled all the way to
Iceland to play a fellow compatriot and
I believe he's one of the oldest players
in the tournament he was born in 1949
which makes him a 73 74 years old if I
can do math it's been a long day and
this was a very long game as you'll see
but uh it was a fun opponent and I do
want to note that sitting next to me was
none other than Anna kramling and she
was streaming her game and there was a
live video feed so I think for most of
her stream you'll see me play a Gregory
in the background and maybe my editor uh
shout out to Jonathan uh we'll inters
for some clips from uh from her stream
yeah let's jump into the game and I did
uh if you see the YouTube title I did
win a special prize for this game which
I will reveal at the end of the video so
uh don't miss it it was a really cool
prize that I'm getting but uh anyway the
game started Pawn D4 I opted for a
London opening but not just any London I
went for a Joe Bava London a very trendy
move order with Knight C3 and the idea
of this is to try and transpose into a
pierce defense if black plays Bishop G7
this is no longer a true King's Indian
because the panzan for and this is one
of my specialty openings for online
Blitz and bullets where white goes for
Queen D2 and long long castling but we
didn't go into that and I was actually
expecting black to play D5 in this
position and I'd found a few of his
games over the last few decades in which
he's played this position and I was
planning to play E3 Bishop G7 H4 which
is a fun line in the style of Joe pava
London but he actually surprised me
instead of playing D5 he played Pawn to
C5
and this is a position which I have
encountered online but I also I had
looked at this a few weeks ago because I
was helping a friend prepare for a
tournament uh in St Louis and my friend
was playing someone who is uh who we
found games that could potentially play
C5 in this position so some of the ideas
were fresh in mind and I knew that the
best move is to take the pawn and
essentially go for a position that
sometimes transposes into an open
Sicilian if black tries to win back the
pawn uh Queen A5 which he didn't play
there's a cool idea Here pawn E4 and if
Queen C5 then it's a pleasant open
Sicilian type structure for whites and
the cool idea with Pawn E4 is that if
Knight takes there's Queen D4 and
there's a lot of initiative for white
here but instead of trying to win back
the pawn right away he was uh just very
quick to complete kingside development
starting with Bishop G7 I went ahead and
played E4 castle and pawn A3 so the idea
of this was to in many cases try and get
in B4 so it essentially prevents Queen
A5 because np4 and queen would be chased
all the way back to d8
so after Pawn A3 it's not entirely clear
how black can try and win back the pawn
on C5 a move like Knight A6 can run into
problems
um maybe Pawn E5 maybe just Bishop takes
A6 as well so he played the move here
which essentially commits to gameting
the move Pawn to B6 so it's an
interesting type of Gambit against this
jobava London setup but it makes a lot
of sense because after I take he takes
and black gets some Initiative for one
the pawn on B2 is hit and there's pretty
quick development on the queen side
Bishop B7 will come with Tempo so here I
defended the pawn with Rook B1 he plays
Bishop B7 I play Bishop two D3 so just
trying to complete development and keep
my Center Pawn defended and then he
played a move which I knew was possible
but I think I had underestimated it when
I saw this position from a distance
uh he played Pawn D5 here which I think
is a very strong thematic move uh just
trying to open up the center before I
can complete development and Castle my
king and one of the big issues here for
white is if I just try and trade usually
it's a good idea to trade when you're up
material uh takes takes takes takes then
we get a position where black has a
double threat of Bishop G2 but also
Bishop A2 so if I defend the g-pawn
bishop A2 and this is actually just a
headache for whites Rook A1 Queen B2 and
then my Rook is essentially trapped on
A1 so
after Pawn to D5 I took I think well one
of my longest thinks of the game uh yeah
we can see from the time stance it took
about 13 minutes to play Queen to E2
um just accepting the fact that I have
to
be a little bit passive and also just a
bit careful in the center I wanted to
play Pawnee 5 here but I couldn't quite
make it work because there's Knights D7
and then if I defend uh black is very
quick to play Queen E6 and this Pawn is
under major uh major pressure from most
of box pieces so I thought we need two
is a safer way to try and cover the
center the drawback of this move is
after Knight D7 Knight F3 the queen
takes away the E2 Square from my knight
and then D4 happens and my knight was
forced back to a very sad place on D1
where it's completely restricted by the
pawn but I thought I was still solid
here like even though the setup for
white is a bit passive and black is a
bit more active
um I thought very soon I'll just be able
to Castle and hold on to the center E4
Pawn is pretty well defended but then
from here he Unleashed a really
impressive series of essentially forcing
moves and I didn't really have time to
Castle as quickly as I wanted he started
with Knight C5 hitting the pawn in E4 I
played Knight D2 and then he plays Queen
E6 hitting the pawn again I play off
three
he plays Knight H5 hitting my Bishop so
it feels like every move I'm getting
punched in the face but I'm still trying
to hold my own like I'm just responding
to every threat that he has but then he
takes my Bishop he takes my other bishop
and then we get a situation where I'm
still up a pawn but black has two
Bishops against two like very passive
Knights and he keeps throwing punches
with a move Rook to C8 and even though
it looks like he's punching thin air he
does have a really annoying threat of
Rook C2 which I felt like I had to
address in this position because I can't
allow The Rook to come in and just
paralyze my Knights and queen so I opted
for Knight C4 here preventing Rook C2
but then uh yeah he keeps punching me uh
Bishop to A6 now attacking the Knight
three times I played the move Pawn to B3
to defend and when I played Pawn B3 I
realized that I'm losing back a pawn
because he can take and whatever I take
back with he has Queen D6 hitting the
undefended A3 and G3 Pawns
um but then he surprised me because
instead of winning the pawn back he
played the move Rook to B8 which I think
was a very nice practical decision on
his Parts
um not being materialistic but putting
the question
what am I doing in this position because
he still has the idea of taking and
queen D6 but now with the threat of
taking on C4 I can't take back with a B
Pawn because of the pin on the B file so
I thought a bit in this position and
decided to play Pawn to F4 which
essentially obstructs the diagonal so it
uh relieves uh the power of Queen to D6
and on top of that I'm having ideas of
playing E5 and trying to restrict the
bishop and also try and weaken the pawn
on D4 but then he takes and of course I
can't take back with b-pawn had to take
the d-pawn and then he plays Queen D6
hitting the pawn on A3
and here I wasn't entirely sure what to
do I really wanted to sacrifice the pawn
and just Castle but I figured it
probably makes sense to defend the pawn
I decided to play Queen to A2 but the
problem with this move is it moves away
from the center and it loses time as
well and it gives back time to push his
d-pawn forward and uh it looks like a
very weird situation with the pawn all
up in my face on D3 it kind of reminded
me of of Moses crossing the Red Sea just
my uh my pawns have parted ways and this
Pawn is just making a run for it and the
pawn is is actually really annoying here
because it's not that easy to attack and
now the bishop has opened So Bach is
having good potential to control the
dark squares so I had to be very careful
here and I decided to finally Castle my
king this was move 23 so kind of late to
Castle but better late than never he
plays Queen D4 Chuck I defend so not
only defend my king but defend the E4
Pawn that was attacked and then he plays
Pawn D2 so Moses is continuing his
journey down the board one square away
from promoting but the good thing for me
is the D1 square is controlled multiple
times so I thought in this position that
the D2 Pawn should really be more of a
weakness than a strength but um as we're
going to see it it gets very tricky
because after Queen C2 he defends with
Rook T8 so creating the battery
supporting the pawn and then I play Pawn
to B4
um I wanted to play Rook T1 but why
didn't I do this
maybe there's something like Queen yeah
like Queen B2 and all of a sudden my
queen side pawns are getting weak and I
still can't take on D2
so I thought B4 is a nice way to
undermine the power of the Rook on B8
and then he plays Queen E3 uh hitting G3
and A3 I saw this move coming and I had
Rook B3 in store uh defending everything
and attacking the queen and then he
plays Queen E2 and looks like he's going
in very very deep but this move was
really annoying because now it's really
hard to remove the queen I can't easily
attack it it's applying constant
pressure keeping the D2 Pawn defended
and supporting the eventual promotion
and I spent a long time here and ended
up playing just a terrible terrible move
and I'll try and explain my thought
process because most of my think I was
looking at Rook to D3 which
um was really my first choice in the
position I thought that this looks like
a nice move diffusing the D file but I
ended up not playing this move because I
I was scared of the line takes takes
takes takes and Rook dates
and I was spending most of my time
calculating this position where the Rook
is now
um attacking the Knight again supporting
the pawn if I move back there's this
really annoying move Bishop to B2 going
after my a pawn and setting up Bishop C1
and I went deeper here I was looking at
Rook B1 and then
Bishop takes and then Knight D1
but then there's some Rook D4 and I just
couldn't really make the lines work in
this position
so I ended up rejecting Rook D3 and
another part of my thought process is of
course like after Queen E2 I I
identified the threat and I saw the the
threat as Bishop to D4 just applying
more pressure pinning the knights and um
then having all these promotion tactics
so that's why I really wanted to play
Rook D3 to prevent Bishop D4 the problem
with my thought process I identified one
threat I didn't identify the other
threats so I saw um I saw I could
prevent Bishop D4 with Pawn E5 another
playing Pawn E5 after having spent most
of my time calculating Rook D3 and I
thought pong E5 it's nice prophylactic
move ensure the bishop can't come in and
cause damage but I completely missed the
additional threats when black played
Queen E2 very straightforward and simple
promotion tactic D1 equals Queen
and oh no black has two queens and this
was not a pleasant situation I'm not
sure if Anna crowling's stream caught
the moment but I was not feeling
good about myself and he was like he was
very confident because uh in this
position my queen is undefended on C2
and I can only take one Queen at a time
so I ended up taking on D1 after takes
takes I'm down a queen for a rook and I
thought about just resigning in this
position given that a player of
pipeline's caliber should be able to win
no problem but
um I wanted to show some fighting
spirits and just try and create some
chances like sometimes in these
situations uh when you're down so much
there's nothing more to lose and I
wanted to put up some resistance
so after Queen takes C4 I doubled up the
Rooks he played H6 I put my Rook on D7
he plays Queen B3 I cover Again cover
the uh the third rank
Queen B2 is played and then I grabbed
the pawn in A7 and like already hear it
it felt like I I had an ounce of Hope
because I have now two connected past
pawns on the queen side E7 Pawn is still
attacked I have Rook D7 ideas to double
up on the seventh Rank and for the time
being my king side is relatively safe
like keeps uh the king safe and the
bishop is basically a dead piece with my
Pawn structure like this so I thought
that like it's not easy for black to win
at this point but then he plays a very
nice move Rook C8 just going for
activity and black is very close to
winning here but I kept resisting
started with Rook F3 allowing Rook C1
King H2 and nice thing about the nylon
F2 is if he doubles up he doesn't really
have a threat because each one is
covered by the Knight so my king is not
instantly getting mated
but then he plays Rook 2 C2 and uh it's
still a big problem for white because my
Knight's pinned so the g-pawn I have to
defend the Knight with the King and then
he plays Pawn G5 and at this point I
thought like I'm very very close to
losing he's come up with a really nice
idea to uh just break down the king side
of a thread in this position is Pawn G4
uh essentially chasing away The Rook or
allowing Knight takes G4 but then
getting in Rook takes G2 and it's very
hard to stop G4 from coming it's also
hard to create a situation where I
stopped G4 and don't allow the bishop to
come in so I ended up throwing in a
check uh provoking King H7 and then
taking the pawn in G5 which does allow
Bishop takes E5 and I thought he was
going to go for Bishop takes E5
um which should just be winning I I have
one check on F7 King G6 and I just don't
have enough counter play with my two
Rooks but he didn't go for Bishop E5 he
instead went for Queen takes E5 and then
I take on H6 and then he surprised me
again because I was expecting Bishop F6
and uh yeah black has everything under
control but he went for a different idea
to play Queenie one king H2 and then
take on F2 and when he went for this
line I had some hope because I was able
to throw in the move Pawn takes G7 uh
threatening to Queen with checks so he
has no time to do anything with these
pieces had to take the pawn and after
takes takes we reached a position of
course I'm still down a queen for a rook
but I have the two connected passers my
king is safe and there's cases where I
can try and uh March up the pawns and um
black has a pass e-pawn so it should be
winning but it still takes a lot of work
uh so here I started with Pawn to B5
just trying to get the pawns rolling he
played Queen B2 I play Pawn A4
and then he plays Queen to B4 and this
is actually a really nice Square for the
queen because I can't easily March up
the pawns either pawn move lose the
other pawn and my Rook Isn't So useful
here because it's tied down to defending
the a pawn and the move I really wanted
to play
um what did I play I played King H3
eventually but the move I wanted to play
was Rook A6 with idea of doing this sort
of caterpillar technique where I I push
push and then expand and then push push
and then expand and then eventually
Queen I think Yasser calls this
caterpillar the problem with this plan
is plaque is very quick to push E5 and
if we just play this out push push push
push if I play Rook A7 E2 and the pawn
is just too close to queening I don't
even have Rook E7 here I was calculating
lines where I play Rook e8s
um I actually spent some time looking
deep into this uh because rookie 8 Queen
takes takes and I wanted to play A6 uh
but uh the two pawns are no match for
the queen that can very simply just
cover and whichever Pawn I push uh yeah
there's Queen in the queen just don't
Mouse slip as black but uh the queen can
go to A6 or here or the king will just
run in like the queen can just stay on
A5 as well so those lines didn't work
and for that reason I did not play
rookie six but instead played King H3
um which essentially is a waiting move
and I realized that my one hope of
saving this position is to try and trade
my queen side pawns for the epon and I
was dreaming of a scenario imagine black
plays Pawn E5 wait didn't he oh he did
play Pawn E5 we don't have to imagine
because this happened on the board
um and then I play rookie Gates
um so imagine a scenario where he takes
on e4 I take on E5 and then let's say
King F6 I can afford to lose a B Pawn
and if we get a situation like this I'm
pretty sure it's a draw because I'll
just put my Rook on F4 and this is uh
essentially a fortress that black I
don't think can break through uh maybe I
can check with table base though table
bass says this is a draw uh fun fact any
position with seven or fewer pieces is
solved uh the super computers have
crunched through all the permutations so
this would have been the dream but
unfortunately uh
dreams don't always come true
and after Pawn E5 rookie eights you did
not take on A4 he played Pawn to F6
um just keeping things covered and now I
was forced to essentially move back keep
my Apon defended and then slowly but
surely I just had to wait he gradually
pushed up with a pawn
um maybe there's some hesitation but
he eventually uh made progress found the
path for his King and I don't think I
want to talk about this game much more
as after check
uh I I was hoping to just paralyze his
King if he doesn't have a queen or a
pawn it would be stalemate but uh that
was not the case and after I played Rook
f8 I immediately saw that I'm losing The
Rook by force and he immediately saw it
too starting with Queen E3 King H2 Queen
H6 and here I resigned and threw in the
towel and yeah it was a tough game
um I made this really unfortunate
tactical oversight but actually after
the game
I I looked at this position with the
engine and it does turn out that Rook D3
was the best move but it also turns out
that I'm losing here um or it's very
close to losing like I actually didn't
realize how much worse I was in the
position and it turns out that the the
d-pawn was way more of a strength than a
weakness so I think I just misjudged
things and I think I may have
underestimated my opponent too this may
have been the oldest player I've ever
lost to in a fide tournament
um but he played a really really nice
game and um even the the opening Gambit
that he played Pawn B6 was engine
approved and like black is apparently
already better after this position so
big kudos to my opponents he was very
friendly after the game too we chatted
for a little bit
um so I do wish him all the best in the
tournament but uh yeah it's tough
another tough game for me um I'm
currently two out of four and now you
might be wondering what's a special
prize that I've gone for playing this
game and losing while the special prize
is because I'm two out of four I'm
playing someone else with two out of
four and that someone else is none other
than Anna crowling uh who's been
streaming and doing Recaps of all her
games in this tournament I was close to
playing her this past round but now I'm
actually playing her tomorrow and this
is not an April Fool's joke
when I initially saw the pairings I
thought it was maybe April Fool's but um
I don't think the tournament organizers
have that sort of sense of humor
so it should be should be a fun fight
um I did play Anna's mom GM Pier
crowdling about a year ago in Gibraltar
and I beat Pia so maybe Anna is looking
for Revenge uh so I'm gonna try and have
this video posted before I play Anna
probably like a little bit before the
round so if you've made it to this point
and you're watching maybe shortly after
this video is posted you can go I'll
leave links in the description uh to the
live broadcast the games are being
broadcast on leeches and chess.com and
Anna will be streaming
um a game live there will be a video
feed and so far her mom pia has been
doing commentary for all her games it's
really good content it's on twitch.tv
slash Anna crownling so do give a follow
and um I guess we'll both be recapping
our game for YouTube afterwards whatever
happens so uh I think now it's time for
me to prepare for Anna I have not done
much preparation I know she's a D4
player so I probably don't want to
reveal too much especially if I post
this video before for the game so I'll
leave it there and stay tuned for the
next one